You know, everybody, welcome to another Zoom call where we have several questions that came in.
Remember to add your questions in the list of all page and feel free to check in some questions while we go here.
Alright, let's jump right into it.
If I genetically do not convert beta-carotene into vitamin A, is there any sense in juicing carrots?
So nobody genetically does not convert beta-carotene into vitamin A.
If you have those gene defects, let me see or whatever they are, then you have a more difficult time in that conversion.
So people that have a lot of defects in that gene family, it would make sense for them to consume more vitamin A even as beta-carotene.
Because you need healthier dose of that in order to have an adequate amount of vitamin A reserves for use in your body.
So yes, to answer this question, if I have that genetic defect where I don't convert or have the possibility of not converting beta-carotene into vitamin A as well as if I didn't have that defect,
is there a sense that you see carrots? Absolutely, there is probably a greater need to do so.
Not that. You can't get beta-carotene and vitamin A from other sources, so I'm not saying that this is a reason to do carrot.
But if you want to do carrot juicing, and you want to gain the nutrients from the carrots that are beta-carotene, it's just one nutrient that you gain from juicing carrots.
So because you have that gene, it would not hinder you from making that decision to do so.
So I would say, yes, go ahead with that.
Next question.
Also, would wheat grass shots be of any value to my daily routine?
Well, wheat grass shots have been touted as big health benefits from a lot of people over the years.
And it can give you a boost of energy. It has nutrients in it and things.
The only negative to wheat grass shots would be the possibility of gluten in them.
Now, it's been studied that wheat grass, if cut at an early stage, I think it's less than 10 to 12 days of growth.
Then it doesn't have gluten, and after that it does have gluten.
So if you have a gluten-sensitivity or stain away from gluten for some reason, you just have to be aware of that.
So if you're getting wheat grass at the grocery store or something, you don't know how old it is, how long it's been since it was cut if you're growing your old wheat grass, that would be a different scenario where you could keep track of that.
If you don't have any gluten-sensitivity and you're not staying away from gluten for any other reason, then that's not something you need to worry about.
Wheat grass shots in general, you can buy wheat grass shots, I think, to add to your smoothies and things like that tend to be fairly expensive.
I have never added them to mine, and I haven't seen a benefit to do so.
But it's the only thing that I'd be aware that I would be careful about is gluten if you have issue of gluten-sensitivity.
What's the best way to treat nausea caused by cancer?
So nausea with cancer patients can be common, and can be difficult because it can decrease the person's appetite, they don't want to eat.
And then if you don't eat and you've lost too much weight, you could go into a state of pakexia, and that can be the most dangerous thing for a cancer patient.
Teapine once weight-up is super important for cancer, for multiple reasons.
If you lose too much weight, you're increased risk of becoming anemic, which brings on other comorbidities.
If you lose too much weight, you're not getting enough protein consumption to make natural killer cells and T cells, which are the lymphocytes, sometimes that are needed to kill cancer.
There's just a lot of negatives to weight loss, and it can always start with nausea.
In our store, we have some homeopathic spray that's called Nausea, that's helped people.
And we have some nausea drops, anti-nausea drops that's helped people, both are homeopaths, so that's something to look at.
I have a blog post on nausea as well, so I look at the blog post that goes into more detail on other hints that you could do to see if that your other hints, as far as diet and food and such, that you could do to help with nausea.
I now have peripheral neuropathy from the chemo, I think that was supposed to say, from the chemo.
What supplements or other things can I do to help with it?
So peripheral neuropathy from chemo is a toxicity neuropathy, meaning that a toxin that stays in your system has the chance of damaging nerves.
Why does it damage peripheral nerves? Because the blood low to get the toxin out of the periphery just from a gravitational standpoint, the toxin is going to have a better chance of settling in one's periphery, in the hands and in the feet.
And thereby damaging the nerves. The longer a toxin is in the vicinity of cells, those cells can be damaged, and if those are nerve cells, those nerve cells can be damaged.
Usually it's the shwan cells, which are the same as the myelin-cheat cells in the upper motor neuron cells in the brain, and the lower motor neurons in the periphery, those are called shwan cells, usually those are damaged causing peripheral neuropathy.
How do you heal from peripheral neuropathy? Well, your B vitamins are beneficial, B6 is a beneficial supplement.
But there's other things other than supplements that are more beneficial. So there's a little machine called a rebuilder.
And that is FDA-approved little apparatus. It looks like the size of a 10-z unit, if you ever use the 10-z unit, but it puts out frequency very specific to nerve reconstruction.
So you put that rebuilder, how it's used, it comes with rubber pads, not stick them, pads, and you put the rubber pads in water and two separate tubs, and you put your feet in those two separate tubs.
You get one of those split tubs that they sell at Walmart or Target, and you put your feet in the water, similar to eye and cleanse, but it won't change the color or anything, because you're just putting frequencies to stimulate nerve, low and nerve growth.
You can put your hands in that tub, you put them in the tub, somebody else turned it up, obviously.
And you turn it up to tolerance, there's instructions that come with the rebuilder.
It is one of the only FDA devices for peripheral neuropathy. It's a great device.
We sell a lot of them, when we were doing more brain-based therapy, we sold a lot of them to people because it is a great brain-based therapy.
It stimulates the cerebellum in the frontal lobe, even if a person doesn't have peripheral neuropathy.
So it can be really good for people with Alzheimer's and Parkinson's as well, but it's really a tool for peripheral neuropathy.
Done at least once a day, 15-bit of session can be extremely beneficial.
If you have access to a PEMF machine, put on a pulse electromagnetic frequency, that can be very beneficial for peripheral neuropathy as well.
So those two tools, a rebuilder, a peripheral, and a PEMF are the best tools for peripheral neuropathy, and then B vitamins are a good nutrient to help the nerves as well.
Where can I find information on stomach issues that start from my cancer, I have indigestion and gas, I don't know if I have food allergies.
Well, always, whenever you're looking for answers to questions, for sure, ask them on the Zoom call here, but always go to our blog so that if there's something other, then you don't have to wait for the Zoom call.
And on our blog, I have information about hypochloridria, which is the most common stomach problem in the world, and hypochloridria, which is a decreased stomach acid production from the stomach cells, leads to long-term hypochloridria, leads to growth of an opportunistic bacteria called helicobacter pylori.
Helicobacter pylori is often called H-pylori for short, H-pylori overgrowth causes damage to the stomach and perpetuates hypochloridria, and it can cause dysbiosis in the gut, it can damage gut wall, it can be the cause of leaky gut syndrome.
It can be, it is the number one cause of stomach cancer worldwide, it can go systemic, it's top five causes of cardiovascular disease, and coronary artery dysfunction.
It's common cause of other cancers elsewhere in the body, it is the number one cause of rosacea rashes on your skin and upper torso, it's a common cause of other skin rashes.
Helicobacter pylori is a gram-negative bacteria similar to lime, so chronic H-pylori is very common, it is, according to the World Health Organization, the number one bacterial infection worldwide, so it's very, very common, it's very easily spread.
So if you, you know, your spouse doesn't eat well and eats garbage and has had stomach issues and ends up with an H-pylori infection, it's very easily spread throughout the family, and it's a bacterial infection, so it, because it is often caught in the chronic phase, often a person with chronic H-pylori.
It doesn't even show elevated white blood cells, so, but it's not uncommon that I'll look at somebody's CBC report and see a slight elevation of white blood cells, remember normal lab findings of lab tests typically give normal lab values of total white blood cell count,
anywhere between 4 and 11 or 4 and 11.5 or 4.5 and 11.5, something like that, but the critical functional lab values of white blood cell count should really be about 4.5 to 7, anything over 7 or 7.5 beans that you have an infection.
And depending on how high it is, it may be a chronic infection, it may be an acute infection, so obviously if you got a white blood cell count over 11, you have an acute infection, but if you have a steady white blood cell, I've had line patients with steady white blood cell counts in the nights that we just can't seem to budge over a long period of time because they have chronic,
Lyme and chronic H-pylori.
Difficult to kill, similar to Borrelia Lyme, where I'm negative bacteria as well, it can hide and disguise itself in the normal Lyme, normal microbiota, it can go intracellular, H-pylori goes intracellular too.
It's difficult to kill, so having a right-fish eat is one of the best ways to kill him.
How do I know if I have that? Well, I have several blog posts on H-pylori in Hypochloridria, so I would suggest you go and look at those and start maybe taking some courses of action regarding that based upon what I write in that blog post.
You can always make it a point with me and we can go over it, we can test for it too.
So looking at a normal CBC and complete metabolic panel, you can get clues of Hypochloridria, you can get clues of chronic infection, but not specific to H-pylori through those tests.
The H-pylori tests that are out there are not super accurate unless you have an active infection either in the blood, so there's three different tests for H-pylori, there's a stool sample test, and that's only going to show if it's active in the stool.
There's a breath H-pylori breath test that's only going to show if it's active in the stomach, and then there's a blood test that's only going to show if it's active in the blood.
The problem is it goes into the tissues and that's where it causes damage, so it's common that you get false negatives, so we need that a person has it, but it doesn't, they're not testing for it.
So it's best to treat based upon symptoms, so I gave some detail in that blog post about that, and to think there's more information on that in the chronic disease and autoimmune course as well.
Next part of this question is, how do I know if I have food allergies? Well, you test for it, so I think the best test for food allergies is the Syrex Arightin, because it tests for IgG and IgM antibodies, and it tests for many of the foods cooked or raw, because it depends on some of the foods have been found that the protein changes if it's cooked versus raw.
And your sensitivity can be too cooked, but not raw or something like that, so it's good to look at both of those things on many of the foods.
Paddy said, you said a few weeks ago that MMS is toxic, what are the scientists, Dr. proponents of MMS who state emphatically that is not toxic, missing what are they missing? Well, well, first of all, everything is toxic at a certain dose.
Vitamin C is going to be toxic at a certain dose, everything is going to be toxic and water is toxic at a certain dose, so you can't say something is not toxic.
Certainly, MMS is, I don't know any good scientists who would say that it's not toxic.
If it was truly a scientist, they would say everything is toxic at a certain dose.
But I don't think that it's toxic at most doses that are recommended.
Where I struggle with MMS is the high doses that are recommended for cancer treatments, because those are very high doses of MMS.
Also, anything that you're taking can, that is, for the purpose of killing bacteria, we used to use MMS, I've said this before, a lot, when we see a lot more line patients, I used to put good percentage of line patients on MMS, it was great results with that.
So it is, I think it's a great antibacterium, but we used to see issues with people's microbiota, so it's similar, but not as potent as an antibiotic, so you'd have to scale that back.
You'd have to ram people up very slowly with MMS too, or they would feel sick.
So you can see symptoms at people, oh, indeed, on MMS, even still well within the non-toxic, quote-unquote, dosage, so you just have to be careful with it, like you're careful with anything else.
I am nothing against somebody using MMS, but just like anything else, you have to be careful.
For instance, you know, we get questions about Fennbedozole, using Fennbedozole, I think Fennbedozole is a great thing for cancer, but you have to keep an eye, I ask people that are on Fennbedozole, could you please get a complete metabolic pedal on a very regular basis?
Because I have seen many times people on Fennbedozole, it spikes their ALT, AST, and alkaline phosphatase. Those are signs of liver toxicity, so you've got to keep an eye on that.
So anything, I think Fennbedozole is a good drug to kill cancer, but you have to be careful of its toxicity, and understand, taking these people are taking Fennbedozole at a dosage that is given to a 10 pound dog.
It's far below the human dosage use of Mennbedozole, so it's anything can be toxic even at far below its LD, what's called the lethal dose, far below it can be toxic to any given human being depending on how that human being metabolizes it.
So anything can be toxic to me based on how I am able to metabolize that and how I am able to detoxify it.
So whatever you're taking something that has a greater chance of that, I suggest you stay on top of looking at your complete metabolic panel and do a CBC at the same time,
so that you're making sure that you're not toxified your liver, because you could end up with a liver failure. I mean, understand, statistically there's over 15,000 people a year in the United States that die from Tylenol,
well, dose adequately according to label, why is that? Because it 80 drug can be toxic, anything can be toxic.
So, you know, typically, yes, typically those are people with other comorbidities, absolutely, they're not just a normal person like, oh, I'm going to take Tylenol for a headache and I haven't taken it for six months.
Typically, they're people that are ill with other comorbidities typically, you know, could also say that those people are taking Tylenol every day and they're using it every day for their headaches that they have every day, because they're not dealing with underlining problems.
There's probably a lot of people in that category, but, you know, a person that's taking bed meds off of their cancer, they're taking it every day, and a person that's taking MMS for their cancer, they're taking it every day, just keep an eye on your liver markers. That's all I'm saying.
Just keep an eye on that, keep an eye on symptoms paid, like I'm getting this weird pain or my liver gall bladder area that I don't usually get, that's very common when you have liver toxicity.
So if you don't have time to go get your complete metabolic panel, paid over the liver area, it could be an early indicator of that is maybe just good to pulse these things.
So whenever I see that with the person that's been beddissolved, I'm taking them off with a beddissolved, you're off for a month till we get these numbers back in order, and I've had some people like, I really want to get back on this, I really think this is helping me.
Okay, but you're going to die of liver failure. So we've got to go off for a period of time and tell these numbers, come back to normal, and then they can go back on it again.
So, but you've got to keep an eye on that, that's all you've got to do, just be careful. Any other questions?
Okay, well thank you guys for today again. We'll have this up for everybody, and just wish everybody a great rest of the week.
Give me a hall air if you need anything. Love y'all, bye-bye.